also leute warten die moral der
geschichte meinen vater auf youtube ist
ein willkommen zu einem neuen video ich
saß letztens mit lukas max in köln und
dann die beiden du bist nur um google
kann bitte nach ausgeguckt und haben
eine entdeckung gemacht luca meinte zu
mir
liga weiß was besser dürfte noch ein sk
auf youtube noch eines gewiss es gibt es
ksk hat nicht geklappt also ich finde da
gibt's noch einen wirklich gibt noch
eine andere kanal so herter fakten
verletzten faker wenn mir die ganze zeit
mit ärger gehabt und ich habe nicht
gemerkt
[Musik]
heute ist tatsächlich so ich hab einen
shaker und wir werden uns heute einmal
die videos anschauen werden gucken was
er gemacht werden mal so seine strategie
analysieren warum er das vielleicht auch
macht und werden uns einfach mal
ratinger pro kanal geben und darauf
reagieren der kanal von dem ich rede ist
selbstverständlich
[Musik]
okay der kanal 110000 195 abonnenten
über 77 millionen aufrufe das ist das
ist mehr als ich beigetreten am 25
2016 und diebe schaden aufkommt du dir
auch bücher youtube-channel of the
movies s t mobile premium in one of the
television production hause von mietern
in die asg group verbindet deutsch werde
auf bengali entertainment bieten von
mode entdeckt
wahrscheinlich warum ist das vorlese
leute schauen auf das land der kanal
kommt aus indien und wirklich schon so
weit heutzutage der welt dass menschen
aus asien leute aus europa f3 kopieren
ihre ideen klauen und einfach alles
gleich machen und damit noch mehr gewinn
machen wir noch mehr erreicht als die
eigentliche erfinder der idee lediglich
für mich ganz zumindest denn dieser
kanal hat die partie mit der
beschreibung schon gelesen ist ein
filmstudio mitmachen ok alles klar wir
sind schon mal das banner das ist auf
jeden fall wer professionell muss ich
sagen und das wirkt überhaupt nicht
seltsam und ein lachs covers mit jeweils
das lustigste leute ich weiß du da warst
lag heißt weil ich war ja mein indiens
hat man in dem praktikum gemacht haben
monaten in denen gelebt deswegen weiß
ich dass lag hunderttausend ist wenn
ihnen ihr sagen einfach lack 300.000
rasch wieder mal lag gehabt wieder
100.000 autos gehabt klagt ebenfalls für
mich auf deine schnauze gefallen wird
aber jetzt zeigen wir direkt aktiv ein
und schauen wann welche videos weg
gemacht und dafür dass auch heute was
hochgeladen dafür die highstreet hahn
agent in manama der im roman das video
jedoch genauso letzten test hochgeladen
hier hat ja jona neue kompost papier
e-mail romano studio kam vor einer woche
bei mir und da unten alte schwede jetzt
bist du viel hot and sexy loket in
gescher valascia criminal vor zwei
wochen kam genau dafür über 80 feste wer
darauf klickt
ok
[Musik]
one
alright
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ich sehe dass unser augenmerk jetzt alle
mit
das ist wirklich harten facts wie alter
die stehen ja erlaubt auf youtube videos
rumstehen was passiert wenn ich jetzt
eigentlich in dem video so einfach schön
so zum beispiel wird
[Musik]
was zur hölle ist wird weil sie in ihrem
vorherigen leben war verkehrt politik
benötigt wird
ja ok sie dürfen nicht abheben jetzt
hier gerade ein moment wieder helfen ja
da drüben okay hier völlig allein dieses
standbild ein was zur hölle ist mein
betrieb braucht semperit in dem video
ist mega store für die augen anfang
gesehen so und die alte wirtin irgendwie
rumkriegen oder so unschuldig einen
gesichtsausdruck an leute möglichkeit
zum auftakt aber wissen was läuft falsch
an dieser stelle aufhören wir müssen
noch weiter recherchieren bedürfnisse
die letzten aktuellsten die von dem
kanal einstellen um wirklich zu
verstehen was da abgeht sondern wir
schauen uns auch noch mal die
erfolgreichsten gehe von den ach du
scheiße 5 mio vj 2 vj 4,6 millionen 3,5
75 millionen 33 9 millionen
das habe ich falsch gemacht in meiner
youtube karriere was ist das haribo
torque cool video she karitativ keine
trabant ii raúl des ladies bengalisch
song 2016 alles da was man auch ich
glaube ich erkenn prinzip dahinter leute
und zwar durch die preise einfach um
rein und dann realität für unrichtige
video haben wir einfach euren kopf auf
die tastatur
ok perfekten was man auf jeden fall
nicht fehlen darf ist in daun flash und
latest bengali movie 2016 und dann
sollte es eigentlich klappen mit dem
fucking 5 millionen aufrufen aber
schauen wir voran leute kommen ok so ein
bisschen was der leute ist ist man
wissen dass es ist einfach nur eine frau
die mal ganz dringend auf toilette muss
in einer europäischen großstadt was
natürlich in einem indischen film sinn
macht mich traurig dass gegangen
dass der retter dass die zuständige
person vom ordnungsamt der europäischen
großstädte seien kein boden toilette ist
hier etwas mit der brille kostet kostet
150 euro das sind einfach mal 10.000
rupien okay es gibt menschen in indien
also in dem land auf dem du
wahrscheinlich herkommen die verdienen
im monat 1000 rupien oder weniger ja
also du hast gerade das thema vom
monatsgehalt von einfachen indischen
arbeiter weggeworfen wie ich erklären
wird achtung wir haben britische fahrer
dem hintergrund gesehen alles klar die
stadt ist höchstwahrscheinlich london
mittel von london das sind doch
belästigung an die will einfach wissen
wo die fucking toilette ist und er macht
die totale anfänger du willst beim
packen ordnungsamt in london zuständig
sein job er ist der frau die toilette
ist sich die an zu machen
[Musik]
mit dem fahrrad alles klar rotes fahrrad
ja hat er locker hat glocker gerade eben
beklaut foto fakt nächste tag der typ
ist wieder da er sie beauftragt 8 wer
wirklich gemein gefährdet hatte sich von
hinten gerade an die frau eingeschlichen
kauft auf einmal hinter ihr auch wie was
ich in serienmörder irgendeines kopf es
ist das denn alter noch weiter die hätte
vielleicht auch mal beim bh anziehen
sollen
ich hatte immer
würde
[Musik]
also leute machen die moral der
geschichte meint egger auf youtube ist
ein indisches filmstudio sehr gut
dargestellt mal für die info und wenn
ihr in london seit gebt acht vor indisch
oder pakistanisch ausstehenden
angestellten des ordnungsamtes jahr
fakten nicht wo die nächste fläche ist
denn mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit werden
sie versuchen euch um zu kriegen und
dabei erfolg kommen leute alles klar
leute lassen like da ein achtes erotisch
sag ich zurzeit ich hab eine kurze hose
an nicht gar keine
falls es gesagt und tschüs